Після того, як комік Володимир Зеленський
вийшов у лідери останніх президентських опитувань,
у соцмережах його часто почали порівнювати з Рональдом Рейганом.
Мовляв, один із найуспішніших
американських президентів так само прийшов у політику із шоу-бізнесу,
і це не завадило йому ефективно керувати
Сполученими Штатами вісім років.
- Я клоун, и я этим очень горжусь.
При цьому якось "забувають", що
між не вельми успішним Рейганом-актором і
доволі успішним Рейганом-президентом
лежав довгий шлях: пік його акторської кар'єри
припадає на початок сорокових, а президентом він став у 1981-му.
Не одразу з концертних майданчиків у політику
приходили й інші представники шоу-бізу.
Про їхній шлях - у добірці DW.
Сороковий президент США Рональд Рейган
був радіоведучим та кіноактором і знявся
у більш ніж 50 фільмах. Щоправда,
акторська кар’єра була нетривалою і
не принесла йому великої слави та впізнаваності.
Рейган став президентом США, коли йому було
майже 70. До того він вісім років прослужив у армії,
очолював профспілку голівудських акторів,
був членом спершу демократичної, а потім -
республіканської партії США, губернатором Каліфорнії
і зрештою двічі обирався на посаду президента.
Загалом Рейган, якого американці називали "лідером нації",
займався політикою більше 30 років. Він заклав
основи нового економічного курсу - "рейганоміки" -
та разом із Михайлом Горбачовим та Гельмутом Колем
поклав край "холодній війні" з СРСР.
Іще один приклад успішних акторів-політиків у США
- Арнольд Шварценеґґер. Бодібілдер і зірка Голівуду,
та ще й австрієць за походженням,
який лише в віці 21 року переїхав до США,
став другим актором після Рейгана, якого обрали
губернатором штату Каліфорнія. Втім, долучатися
до політичного життя США Шварценеґґер почав
задовго до цього, взявши участь у передвиборній кампанії
Джорджа Буша-старшого. На посаді
губернатора Каліфорнії Шварценеґґер пробув два терміни.
У своїй політиці робив великий акцент на захист довкілля.
Саме він став ініціатором запровадження
найжорсткіших вимог щодо викидів парникових газів з усіх, які існували у США.
Також Шварценеґґер розпочав кампанію
за скорочення видатків, відмовився
від губернаторської зарплати у 175 тисяч доларів і
під час губернаторства не знімався в кіно.
Цікавим представником шоу-бізу в політиці
є колишній мер Рейк’явіка,
ісландський комік Йон Гнарр. Засновник "Найкращої партії",
яка позиціонувала  себе як "відверто корумпована",
пародіював опонентів, присягаючись не виконувати
свої передвиборні обіцянки. Втім, усе це не завадило
Гнарру перемогти на виборах мера та керувати
ісландською столицею чотири роки. На цій посаді
він досяг неабияких успіхів, адже за правління Гнарра
в місті провели шкільну реформу, навели лад
у міських фінансах, а також досягли туристичного буму.
Цікаво, що напередодні нових виборів Гнарр
оголосив про розпуск партії і відмову балотуватися на другий термін.
Це мало відрізняти його від звичайних політиків, які
всіма силами намагаються зачепитися за владу.
До приходу в політику італійський
комік-парламентарій Беппе Ґрілло тривалий час
виступав у кабаре і на телебаченні. Спершу він
глузував із політичної еліти Італії, а потім і собі
вирішив податися в політику, заснувавши 10 років тому "Рух п’яти зірок".
Партія з євроскептичними та популістичними гаслами
- змінити все старе на нове - швидко набула
популярності, і хоча і з другої спроби, але перемогла
на торішніх виборах в Італії. Щоправда, попри
гучні гасла, обіцяне в життя ця політсила так і не втілила.
Нині Ґрілло відійшов від політичних справ
і не займає важливих посад.
Тим часом Володимир Зеленський
про свої політичні амбіції ніколи не заявляв. По суті,
комік потрапив до президентських рейтингів
завдяки соціологам і довго вагався щодо своєї участі в виборах.
І навіть попри участь у перегонах Зеленський
усе одно залишається актором і гастролює по Україні.